I do think that there are a subset of
men that get insecure when the lady in
their life they don't feel as though
that they can provide for them because
she will make she makes significantly
more money I do think that that does
talk uh Target some men as they're
dating so what I found is that if you
treat him like he's the man he don't
care I'm with you and so like the
problem is the girls will act like
they're better than everyone I don't
think I'm better how okay how am I going
to be better than a guy let's just say
let's not think of a normal job like
like a fireman imagine putting out fires
or police officers I'm not better than
them well I just talk for a little